watch this with Just 4 seconds on the
clock I think he made those quick moves
to gain the incurrent reminder to
everybody 3 seconds added every single
move you make so a quick check go block
that pawn and then push your own pawns
Fabby can win this game even if he loses
Queen for those two pawns then he can
push the Pawns of his own a rook can
stop but give away with check wow he
just blundered the pawn with check he
should have pushed the other one the G
Pawn wrong choice there and Magnus is
alive look at those white pawns
paralyzing the black queen and this can
be scary for black because now the queen
can't move anywhere with the check
without allowing the dewn to promote and
Magnus is does he have enough to hold
this well the problem for Magnus is that
gon will be a decoy it's not to
sacrifice himself The Rook on D3 can't
move because the D7 Pawn in front of the
queen will be captured both sides
they're struggling a bit here five
doesn't know where to go but now it's
winning for Magnus he brings his Rook
all the way down Rook it he chooses the
wrong Square he trapped his own Queen
and it's handshakes Magnus gson does the
unbelievable he wins down a queen